fumer sur une scène de théâtre.
Cette décision, rendue ce matin
par la cour du Qe le milieu thé.
Kassandra Nadeau-Lamarche.
- Ces comédiens ne pouvaientscè,
même si la cigarette faisait
partiepartiepartiepartie de la .
La Cour du Québec confirme
l'interdiction, à laquellede Qu.
ANNE-MARIE OLIVIER, dir.
ique, Théâtre du Trident
- Tant que la cigarette
va exister dans la vie,
et que notre métier est
il faut trouver une façon
de pouvoir fumer sur scène.
- Entre 2017 et 2019,
les théâtres de la Bordée,
du Trident et Premier Acte
ont tour à tir fait
fumer des acteurs sur scène.
on qu'ils ont contestée,
se disant même prêts à faire
des compromis.ique,ique,ique,iq,
Théâtre la Bordée
e disait : bien,
peut-être qu'il pouvait avoir
quelque chose qui pouvait,vre
et le chou, s'il y avaitun aver,
quand on achète un billet,
quelque chose.on, le juge,
Yannick Couture, conclut :
Il aj
- Faut que ce soit réaliste.
Si on fait semblant,
le spe
Il ajoute que :
- Faut que ce soit réaliste.
Si on fait sembl ça,
on l'avait bien expliqué
au juge.
Me LOUIS-PHILIPPE LAMPRON,
avocat au dossier
- Qu'un scènen scènen scènen sc,
par un auteur, en fait,
quand n rôle
où l'acteur va fumer,
que ça ne soit pas considéré
comme s passablement
étonné.
- Les compagnies estiment aussi
les murs des théâtres.
- On parle aussi des plate
de cinéma, des studios de télé.
Si quelqu'un se plaint,
- Les gestionnaires
des trois théâtres doi
se rencontrer demain pour
discuter de la suite des chosess
pour déterminer s'ils vont
porter leur cause en appel.rche,
Radio-Canada, Québec.